usually when talking about whether or
not space is discretized or on a lattice
in some way people say well we have
these fluids and then as you investigate
further you find out that they're atoms
and we thought that they were continuous
but then as you investigate the atoms
further you'll you find out that they're
quantum fields and obviously then you
can say well those quantum fields are
discretized do you think that there's
a place in your models for
continuity underneath
what seems like discrete points so
let me be a little bit more specific
anything that i can think of as
continuous there's some way maybe a
simplicial decomposition to make it
discrete but then also the same you can
apply step functions of a certain width
from something continuous to make
something discrete so when someone says
well this is obviously discrete well
the argument can
can be turned on its head the thing to
understand the formalism of our models
is probably most humanly stated in terms
of hypographs and things like that
but
it is
basically certainly the case that there
are for example algebraic formulations
of what we're doing in fact some of the
things from category theory look that
way
where you can think about it as
features of some continuous space you
know it is you know some algebraic
geometry feature of some continuous
space et cetera et cetera et cetera the
net result is
it's just the same as this hyper graph
but it is presented as something that
looks like uh you know
topological uh you know aspects of the
homotopies of continuous spaces or
something
um but it looks like but but a different
interpretation is that it's just this
hyper graph so there's nothing
particularly special about this
hypergraph except that it's the most
human
relatable version of what's going on
i'll give you an analogy
in theory of computation
you can think about lambda calculus you
can think about combinators you can
think about register machines or you can
think about turing machines
turing machines are the
you know at least in the early such
systems were the most human relatable
you know way of thinking about
computation
and i think that there are different
formulations of our models
that
some of them we can see now some of them
will probably emerge in the future that
look different with respect to that now
there's a more extreme possibility
which i don't know if it's the case
and i'm trying to not repeat mistakes of
history so to speak here you know when
einstein invented general artillery one
of the things that uh came up was
the theory as he first set it up
implied that the universe expands
and he was like that can't possibly be
right
you know surely that isn't right so let
me add this extra cosmological term
to uh to prevent the cosmological
constant and so on to prevent the
universe from expanding well turned out
it was true that the universe expanded
and he shouldn't worry too much about it
well in our models the most obvious
possibility
is that this
hypergraph is progressively subdividing
itself it's getting bigger and bigger
and bigger um and the the distance one
meter
is corresponding to more and more and
more
sort of separate atoms of space if you
line them up and looked at their
connections and so on it will be a
larger number of connections that would
have to be made to correspond to a meter
of physical space
so one thing which i have to say it does
look in these models is if it's
suggesting it's the way it happens is
that in fact the amount of the number of
atoms of space is rapidly increasing in
the history of the universe
and if that's the case one of the most
bizarre possibilities is
you say
okay you say i've got an experiment it's
going to test whether the universe is
discrete
as i run the experiment the universe is
subdividing itself so if the experiment
said i'm going to test is the universe
discrete at the level of 10 to the minus
200 meters by the time that experiment
has been run the universe will have
subdivided itself to be 210 2 10 to the
minus 220 meters or something and so in
other words it will always be running
away from you it will always be
subdividing itself faster than you can
determine its subdivision it's kind of
like the ultimate epsilon delta proof in
in calculus or something